Mikey scared of everything,
finds a book
that he finds,
it's called the dragon,
the prince.
And he's scared to read it cause the pictures a scary dragons in it.
But then he gets the courage to read it because he sees a little boy in there
too.
That kind of looks like he knows what's going on.
So he sees that little blankets.
I'm gonna read it and in the book the king is dead
and the boy is now the only one that will defend the kingdom from the dragon
center over the hill.
It's dragging cave and the boys scared cause he only seven years old,
he doesn't know he's going to do it.
Goes and finds its farmers.
Your war chest was out,
the shield pulls up the sword,
they're too big for him and now he's even more scared.
But then he sees a note in the bottom of the war chest and he picks up the note
and here's what it says,
my son,
our kingdom is now what you must save.
I need to do that.
You have to be brave.
The dragons,
they aren't really that big at all.
It is only in our minds that we make them so tall inside.
Our brains think he's always get overblown,
especially things that are completely unknown.
Stand up straight and hold your head high and look your fears right in the eye.
Don't look away.
Don't try to hide.
No that you have great strength.
Deep inside
fear is normal for every person on earth.
This is where I hero.